le festival d'avignon le plus
spectaculaire rassemblement culturel de
l'été s'apprête à proposer jusqu'au 4
août quelques 350 représentations de
théâtre de danse de musique et d'opéra
plus de 80000 places sont d'ailleurs
déjà été vendus en ce moment même ce 4
ce 42e festival d'avignon ouvre par une
version intégrale du hamlet de
shakespeare mise en scène par patrice
chéreau pour son théâtre des amandiers
de nanterre dans la cour d'honneur du
palais des papes
un spectacle de près de cinq heures dont
elisabeth qu'il est bien suivi les
répétitions dans la distribution on
relève les noms de robin renucci marthe
keller et gérard desarthe dans le rôle
d'hamlet hamlet que l'on retrouve tout
de suite en plein affrontement avec
ophélie
j'ai aussi entendu parler et bien trop
de vos parts pillages dieu vous a donné
un visage et vous vous en faites un
autre vous tortiller vous trottiner vous
minauder vous donner des surnoms à ce
que dieu a créé vous êtes bien public
sous des airs d'innocence
allez
je pense qu'au delà de l'ambition de
vouloir réaliser un beau spectacle
c'est même pas le problème sur hamlet je
crois qu'il faut affronter cette oeuvre
parce qu'on a un peu le devoir de
l'affronter la même façon qu'un grand
soliste un grand pianiste l'affronter
certains constatent au très difficile
sinon on n'avancera pas s'ils se
contentent des choses les plus simples
les plus évidentes
en l'absence d' évidence de d'hamlet est
une chose qu'il faut affronter une fois
lancé le hamlet c'est d'abord une
histoire qu'il faut bien raconté le
suspense policier avec meurtres en quête
et des personnages dont le désir ou la
haine fou porté à l'incandescence mais
d'identité le sort du meurtrier importe
moins qu'une autre en quête métaphysique
elle qui bute sur des murs opaque
pendant près de six heures la mise en
scène de chez ouvre des abymes qui n'ont
rien des littéraires et lui c'est plus
que jamais utilisé la beauté vous
permettra d idées de déclencher
l'émotion quand vous parlez de l'idéal
de mise au sein des toujours des
mobilités clarté qui vous viennent à la
brousse pour hamlet en particulier mais
ces spectacles sont des personnages
j'ai aussi complexe énigmatique aussi
mais je sois raconter simplement
illégale manque parce que c'est comme ça
que c'est écrit c'est dire que c'est
très évident quand on lit la pièce quand
on la lit à la fois est totalement
énigmatique sur le sujet de la pièce est
une énigme pourquoi n'agit-il pas c'est
une énigme bien et je n'ai pas ce qu'il
ya une réponse et en même temps elle est
écrite d'une façon très fraternel très
généreuse et très libre est vraiment
très simple abandonné shakespeare montre
ce qu'il a envie de montrer au moment où
il a envie de le faire voir et c'est un
peu 7 7 7 pénalités comme ça qu'il faut
aussi de retrouver la condition qu'elles
soient nourris jeudi on s'est posé
énormément de problèmes on a refait 25
fois la mise en scène des scènes pressé
de trouver une sorte d'évidence aller
comme le fauconnier pensait qu'il a je
leur patte sur tout ce qu'ils voient pas
les flics une tirade avec quelque chose
de passionnés vous êtes des cous a des
affinités personnelles avec avec hamlet
oui je ne pensais pas avoir avant au
moment de choisir
oui oui tout à fait tout à fait et
j'espère que le ça se verra notre
crainte tout à fait mais sur des choses
secrètes les deux fois parce qu'elle
elle parle de choses secrètes qui ne
serait pas bien dire mais qu'elle dit
mieux que nous oui oui vous avez aperçu
le sourire de patrice chéreau et c'est
rare chez cet homme secret